twenty thousand words his 50th
anniversary is anybody telling you that
he may start talking about succession or
pinpointing who could succeed him yeah i
mean i think it's it's it's a near
certainty that he's going to talk about
succession it's a big question on a lot
of people's minds but the the real
question is you know how specific is he
gonna get he's used this letter in the
past couple of years to talk about
succession but he always talks about it
sort of in a in a in a way that doesn't
reveal a ton of details so you know
while there's always the possibility
that he could name a successor you know
what I'm hearing right now is is that
we'll get an update but but but perhaps
not the name of the successor right as
far as we know there's some envelope
somewhere in Omaha spittin in his desk
and the board knows and it's one person
we believe right it's one person who
would be who would succeed him well yeah
I mean he said that publicly over the
years that the board is in agreement on
on who they're leading candidate is and
that they have a couple of backups so
yes exactly and there's a couple of
other broad themes are gonna be covered
what are they gonna be Noah yeah well
there's a bunch of stuff you know for
people who cover the the company closely
there's a couple of you know insider
baseball type things you know he's got
these investment managers Todd combs and
Ted Weschler who've been working for him
for a couple of years so it might be
interesting to see what what their
returns had been over that period we
haven't gotten a ton of detail on that
another thing he's been buying companies
or partnering with 3g capital it's it's
a buyout firm so an update on on that
partnership would be interesting and
then you know a really big thing also on
the theme of mergers and acquisition is
acquisitions is just what Buffett's
going to do with all this cash he has
more than sixty billion dollars of it on
the balance sheet right now and he
hasn't done a major major deal in a
while now and he hasn't and you know we
were talking earlier about this German a
publication
that had done an interview with him
recently where he said look maybe
Germany there's a possibility of buying
something there may be somewhere in in
Europe I mean what do you make every
once in a while you'll hear that Buffett
is interested in Europe he's interested
in Asia what do you make of this latest
report I i mean i think it's it's smart
on his part right he needs to put an
advertisement out there and and saying
that he's ready and willing to buy they
did berkshire did by a company in
Germany that got announced last week it
was relatively small but you know when
you do something like that it's it's a
great opportunity to say to other
business owners hey we're here we have
cash and we're looking to buy